[Music]
you know if you still don't believe that
there is a racism crisis in this country
then let me tell you a story that may
change your mind
according to an urgent and exclusive
report from fox 5 in dc a firefighter in
alexandria has been put on
administrative leave because he made a
quote controversial gesture while on
camera during a recent news segment
and this firefighter it appears moved
his fingers in a in a way
that may seem totally benign and
incidental to the untrained observer but
the heroic investigative journalists
over at fox 5 know that quite often the
most insidious forms of racism can be
hiding in plain sight so we'll play this
report for you now and it's it's a
little bit long but
it's it's worth listening to every
single moment of this and keep in mind
as you listen to it
this is very real okay this is not a
parody not a joke at least not
intentionally
listen to this
well only on fox 5 an alexandria fire
department member is in hot water being
investigated for possibly flashing a
racist symbol on our air fox 5's
stephanie ramirez is live in alexandria
at station four and stephanie how did
this end up happening
well rob this was during a live fox 5
zip trip segment that we were doing last
friday we do these in the community to
highlight different communities all
across our region well during the last
friday event in alexandria a fire
department member decided to flash what
is the okay gesture as the camera was
passing by we confirmed with fire
department officials today that that
member has just been placed on
administrative leave with pay now it
happened so quickly it's kind of hard to
catch here but it is the last alexandria
fire department member on the right who
first makes fists and then does that
okay gesture just before the camera cuts
to our two anchors a viewer email came
into fox 5 shortly after with a screen
grab of this member the emailer asking
why there's a gang symbol on tv stating
it needs to be addressed we asked the
department about it now we should note
here the okay hand symbol it was used as
part of a punching game if you flashed
it it is used by scuba divers
communicating underwater it's also
listed by the anti-defamation league as
a gesture of hate sometimes used to
express white power now i did get to ask
the fire chief today about it if he knew
the member's intention behind doing this
chief corey smedley told me no that he
has not talked to this member yet but
there will be an investigation i also
asked what if it turns out that he was
or this was done out of some kind of
joke
a joke is only if someone is not
offended by it
and it's always in the eyes of the
beholder and just because someone may
have thought things were a joke it does
is not something that is up to our
values within the department so we have
to first and foremost make
every attempt to maintain the integrity
and trust of the community and joking is
not something that is part of our
mission
it's hard to know where to begin in
sifting through this madness the anchor
reporting live from the scene of where a
dude moved his fingers
says that the okay gesture where you
form a circle with your index uh finger
and thumb is a gesture of hate
well more specifically she says that it
can be it can be part of a punching game
or it it's a sign
used by scuba divers divers
uh or it could be a secret white power
symbol those are the options
son you're either a scuba diver or a
nazi
and we ain't under the ocean right now
so that kind of narrows it down a little
bit of a full metal jacket thing going
on i guess
she does clarify of course that the adl
the anti-defamation league has declared
that the okay sign is a hate symbol what
she doesn't explain however is why
anyone should give a damn
what the adl thinks
there's a handful of far left political
groups the adl southern poverty law
center principle among them that have
appointed themselves sort of arbiters of
what is hateful and what is what is not
and they get to decide which gestures
and words and ideas and groups are valid
and which are abhorrent and accursed
we're not supposed to ask why
or rather where they derive this
authority or why we should respect or
care about their opinion on these
matters
the media will simply say well the adl
says this is hateful so
well i care what they say
why should who who put them in charge
it's not unlike the groups that have
declared themselves fact checkers
and now because they have fact checker
in their name they're meant to be
unquestionable
unquestionably trusted as as the
official adjudicators of truth
but the funny thing is that if you go to
the adl's official website and their
database for hate symbols
it does list the okay gesture and yet it
admits that the whole white power
connection is really a trolling campaign
by 4chan so here's what their website
says it says
a common hand gesture that a 4chan
trolling campaign claimed in 2017 had
been appropriated as a symbol meaning
white power
used by many on the right not just
extremists for the purpose of trolling
liberals
the symbol eventually came to be used by
actual white supremacists as well
caution must be used in evaluating
instances of this symbol's use uh okay
so
the okay gesture could be a white power
symbol allegedly or it could be a scuba
diver sign or it could be a game that
you play where if somebody looks at the
circle then you get punched that's when
i was a kid that's
that's what that's what that's that's
what it usually meant when someone did
that it meant that the punch was coming
shortly after you saw it or it could be
a 4chan troll or it could just mean okay
or it could mean a dozen other things or
it could mean nothing at all
not every movement a person makes with
their fingers
has some deep-seated reason behind it in
fact most movements don't most are
incidental
if you were to stare at a person's hands
long enough
and film it
looking for hidden meanings you know
behind every twitch or gesture you'll
come away thinking that they might they
made white power symbols they they
flashed gang symbols they flipped you
off they i don't know they they said the
words train and dog and sign language i
mean all kinds of random things
and the person will have communicated
these messages
to you without knowing that they
communicated anything at all kind of
like the truck driver for the gas
company in california last year who was
fired
for making the same white power sign
when really it turned out he was just
cracking his knuckles which is a pretty
you know you do this and you crack your
knuckles
also he's mexican but they still fired
him
for being an advocate of white power
but somehow we haven't even gotten to
the dumbest part of this alleged uh
news report yet
because the dumbest part comes to us
courtesy of the fire chief chief smedley
a perfectly appropriate name somehow
it's it's just
you hear chief smedley and then you you
see him and you listen to him and you
think well yeah that's that's exactly
what i expected from chief smedley so
chiefs medley says that uh even if the
benign probably incidental finger
movement
was actually intended as a joke
it doesn't count as a joke anymore if
someone gets offended exact quote a joke
is only if someone is not offended by it
which i guess that's news to uh
that would be news to to uh i mean
many comedians richard pryor was it was
apparently he never told a joke in his
life his whole career
we think of him as an iconic
trailblazing comedian but uh he's not at
all he's he was not a comedian he was
not a comedian because he probably
offended people with every joke that he
told
but it's all in the eye of the beholder
chief smedley says and if someone hears
or sees your joke and decides that they
don't like it
then all of a sudden your joke isn't a
joke anymore
if they interpret it as something
serious then that means that your
intentions were serious so they get to
retroactively determine
what your own intentions were based on
how your joke makes them feel
that's chief's medley's position
that's the media's position
that's everyone on the left that's
that's how they look at it
and that's why he says joking is not a
part of our mission
that's the most chief smedly thing
anyone has ever said joking is really
not a part of our mission here
but this this this idea
um which has led to the the unjust
cancellation of many a person
this idea that your your intentions
don't matter at all
in communication
so when you're communicating something
what you intended in communicating it
makes no difference all that matters is
the the person listening to it and how
they feel when they hear you say it so
even if you weren't trying to
communicate anything at all even if
you're just standing there and moving
your fingers randomly
and there's no intention
doesn't matter because someone felt
differently and they get to decide what
your intentions were not you them
all of this is quite insane of course
and it would be hilarious if not for the
fact that an innocent man's life is
being severely impacted by it just
imagine imagine from the firefighters
perspective for a moment here
fox 5 shows up because they want to do
some dumb filler segment
um and you have to put on your uniform
and stand there for the b-roll shots and
they probably did a whole bunch of shots
you're standing out there for you know
45 minutes next thing you know
because some hypersensitive tattletail
with no life and nothing better to do
was offended by the movement of your
fingers now you're under investigation
and suspended from your job and being
smeared on television as a suspected
nazi
and to make matters worse it's being
done by people who almost certainly know
better
they're not as insane as they appear to
be maybe the original person who
reported it
the viewer who saw that and paused and
said what's that there what do you do
with his fingers
that person might just be a psycho
lunatic or simply a loser with nothing
better to do as i said
but the fire chief
well he's a spineless coward
the reporters are sadistic propagandists
perfectly willing to destroy a random
person's life for the sake of a story
especially a story that advances the
preferred narrative
and for all of those reasons that is why
of course fox5 in dc is cancelled and i
have to say most of all
and i never thought i'd have to say this
but chief smedley you are also sir
canceled and that is no joke at all
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated